tell me you know
could you write down the name of that
rehabilitation clinic you mentioned wow
pretty impressive
what does that even say
[Laughter]
well
hello everybody
i tried to do some research once mose
and i rented a movie about a latina
wedding planner with a big fat
mose and i rented a movie about a latina
wedding planner with a big fat ass
i tried to do some research once
no i know nothing about wedding planning
i tried to do some research once mose
and i rented a movie about a latina
wedding planner with
enormous
[Laughter]
this is what we did last time here we go
once fall well
no
it's
it's not it's not anybody's fault you
know what let's just
look at the lines
and then we'll do the scene again
[Laughter]
thank you
you're insane
you are insane i know i didn't even get
to any of our dialogues great
[Laughter]
phyllis did i or did i not say fruit
you did say fruit and what is that
cake and what did i say
fruit
is this is this
is this funny to you phyllis
she's nervous
yeah well she should be nervous because
i'm about to kick her ass
i'm gonna walk in again
now we all think you're liar what would
a liar bring minnie mouse bars
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
bye stanley
[ __ ]
what did you call me
[Laughter]
we're gonna need a signal to bolt out of
there the slightest sign of danger okay
and that signal is lift your lips
let me see
no no no like this
oh no oh dude i'm so sorry
oh
i'm so sorry dude okay
this is deja right
[Music]
come on phyllis come on
oh jesus are you all right
phyllis are you all right are you okay
i'm okay
don't don't you even
keep that in there
oh my god
uh
i think i'm going to need some new pants
[Laughter]
oh
you broke it
you broke it oh
oh
man this bit will never work oh
wow
and
this copier
is
working fine that's the original well
[Laughter]
could not have made a better noise
we're having an earthquake get it on the
dvd
yeah rolling rolling on the earthquake
go on the earthquake
i'm so glad i showed you all the trains
going through scranton we just wanted to
say we're very sorry screw you guys
you're dead to me if you say screw you
one more time
whoa okay guys
i did the face you like if you say screw
you one more time
hey guys
stop doing this
it makes no sense if you say screw you
one more time
hey guys just cool it
you knew
you knew that was that
basically the dynamics of
all right basically within the workplace
[Laughter]
oh
there's always a theme
idiot
about the tickets i know i told
everybody
and then you put it on a wheel you spin
it and you make it into the cup and you
glaze it put in the kiln
and uh
yeah i bought that in the gift shop
though
hey there gorgeous how you doing today
i'm good thank you how's it hanging
all right
listen
my name
so you know what things uh
things i guess aren't aren't so bad
after all
okay
[Laughter]
you either break off your engagement
with that singing buffoon apologize and
then date me or you can say goodbye
to this
i think
phyllis
we gave you one hell of a wedding shower
it was a golden shower phyllis we all
gave you a gold
we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you
we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower
well where's my
golden [ __ ]
i'm gonna try to get to bed by eight
yeah okay
i love you anyway
i love you too
best salesman i ever met in my life
what's his last name
i want to say
i know that's not it he he worked at the
tail marketing place
it's not it but he worked at that time
she she did she had dupu i know that's
not it but he worked at that
just i feel like some of these
directions to shrewd farms are a little
weird um i mean like 156 paces from the
light red mailbox make a left
walk until you hear the beehive
and
make a right if you are
attacked by territorial crows
i have this is really easy
if you smell bear pee
turn the other way
you